oui
bien donc il y a une sonde sats juste sur le
moniteur là-
bas si vous la prenez et si vous la faites glisser
et la placez à côté de sa main
qui devrait cliquer sur son doigt
[Musique]
une gamme de différents masques à oxygène donc
il devrait y avoir
un simple  masque facial là-bas
et un autre
[Musique]
tout au long de l'école de médecine, vous
savez que des patients par intérim viennent pour faire des
scénarios cliniques particuliers, puis nous
avons eu une simulation vr qui est un peu comme
ça mais qui n'utilise pas réellement l'
espace réel c'est juste un écran dans  devant
vos yeux, cela passe
au niveau supérieur où vous mélangez réellement
votre monde réel et votre patient holographique
en termes de médicaments et nous pouvons
réfléchir à celui qui se trouve
devant
nous utilisons la réalité étendue
technologie ainsi que
des scénarios de simulation pour former et enseigner à notre prochaine
génération de personnel de santé
d'une manière plus ciblée
et plus
souple
Je ne dirais jamais que les médecins doivent
sortir des murs et arrêter de voir
des patients et arrêter de parler aux patients
et finalement la simulation n'est pas  va
recréer tous les scénarios que vous allez
avoir et ces moments que vous
avez avec les patients où vous devez
avoir un très bon système de compétences en communication